is it fair to say when things are going
well when you're all winning yeah
everything great when you're losing you
all fall out and it's terrible
I think that's common in all walks of
life when when things are going well
people paper over cracks and when things
start to go wrong people look for
excuses people blame each other but the
one thing I'm proud about in that book
is that Andy flower knows about all of
that stuff in the book before I wrote it
and when we were doing well I was still
complaining about this stuff that I knew
wasn't right with our system and so
that's and that's what I thought and
that's what I've reported and the other
thing I was wondering is because you've
now kind of lived through it all again
writing the book you've gone through
this whole experience you know and you
know we're making light of it a bit but
you know it got pretty grueling for you
at various times it was you know very
personal you yeah and I just wondered
having written all this and gone through
it again are the things you would do
differently or do you look back kind of
thing actually I could have had a lot
better I could have done something yeah
clearly we all make mistakes none of us
are perfect we all make mistakes in
every walk of life and I certainly made
them and what are the biggies what are
the biggie miss what are the one of the
biggest mistakes I made was n distress
when he played it's just before he's
hundreth Test match I was involved in
their text messaging scandal and for me
one of my good friends who was just
about a player's hundreth Test match
playing a hundred Test matches quite a
big thing it's like it's like huge and
he his whole week being the captain of
the side too
you do your chess match and then you
test so he's doing 100 yes yes so
basically I was involved in in that
little bit of a scandal the week before
his hundredth test match he had
basically thought in his mind I'm
finishing at their Test match he had
captained us for a few years he was a
fantastic captain he was a very good
cricketer a good friend of mine I was
involved in a bit of a mix-up and it
just went through the me the next set
should I not ask about that that's
cricket again and basically that just
sort of tarnished his week which should
have been one of the greatest weeks of
his career and I regret that and I feel
so sorry for that and yeah it's sort of
tarnished and hurt our relationship a
little bit which I don't like how do I
put this delicately
reading the book it strikes me that
maybe just made me team sports not for
you
[Applause]
we love started playing go for that I
think really really go for maybe not but
yeah I probably be happy there too but
you love the IPL you were telling me I
do
I love cricket I love it's the best
thing I've been very blessed and
fortunate to have just keep
[Music]
what is that the proper cat I would go
online I would look at their Instagram
pages or their tumblr or their Twitter
or whatever and and just kind of watch
them for months and months